tickets on sale now dude  catch  tickets on sale now dude tickets on sale  now  dude  exclusively in movie theaters  hello peter do i know you we started  getting some visitors from every  universe this is all my fault  i promise i'll fix this  we're gonna get through this  we're gonna get through it together  do you know peter parker who's  spider-man yes is that him no  can you please explain what is going on  after i shut that spell down we started  getting visitors from every universe  multiverse is real  i need you to capture them before they  destroy the fabric of reality i'm gonna  need some help  you guys ready let's catch some  multiverse men  spider-man your way home what was your  name again dr otto octavius seriously  what's your actual name  you